nobody knows how many people died here
how anyone survived this amount of
damage is a near miracle in itself but
whatever the official figures of death
here say they're almost certainly wrong
this was a shanty town known as mud and
pees on Abaco island it doesn't exist
anymore reduced to piles of rubble and
houses two sticks of wood
thousands lived here but many ignored
warnings to evacuate even experienced
disaster hands are shocked by what
happened in credibly some did survive
the storm still somewhat dazed they
spend their days trying to work out what
they're going to do most of these people
are from Haiti at our unofficial
residence so they're getting little help
most have lost everything some have no
idea where family members are split in
the storm and Arthur
Dorian passed at this moment I am
talking to you I don't see my mom I
don't see my son I don't know
I don't know maybe not seen him since
the storm I saw my son after the storm
but after that he drive from here too
cheeky I don't yet know more for me
because we are caught on the leg arm and
do you think a lot more people have died
than the official especially the stories
of survival are remarkable many of the
survivors were injured escaping even at
francois lost two fingers saving her
daughter how did you survive where did
you stay did you live in your house
did you get out so each time you moved a
location it got blown down when you see
the next one gone I send the world as it
would serve me and make many of the
people from this community of absolutely
nowhere to go and no means of getting
there even if they did we are planning
to see to move but we don't know where
we can go on yeah we don't have no place
to go and let them some people can ask
some people then
different island they have some family
someplace the girl but we are and this
in this house we live we don't have
nowhere to go
we don't know what to do we just did
their food in what we don't know what to
do the American military has now arrived
to help with the aid effort military and
civilian planes and helicopters shuttle
supplies into Abaco at the airport small
groups of survivors wait to catch a ride
to the United States or other Bahamian
island the NGOs operation is being led
by Samaritan's Purse they're about to
distribute tarpaulin to make shelters
the damage in this part of Abaco is huge
and they still haven't reached all the
communities by land it's still an ad hoc
operation and it's still an emergency
this type of disaster doesn't end when
the hurricane passes and sometimes it
actually gets worse Sturm see Sky News
Abaco island